you
hi everyone it's Jerry I have another
cool chest puzzle to share with you I
found this one on the chess subreddit
and I'll have a link to that thread in
the description I'm gonna present this
one in a way that I haven't before I'm
gonna give you an opportunity to solve
it blindfolded if you'd like so bear
with me those of you who just want to
see the position straight away here we
go white King a 1 white rook III and
white Queen
g7 black King d8 black rook e8 and black
queen h8 it's white to move what is the
best continuation now if you still want
to solve this blindfolded now would be
the time to relist into what I just said
or pause the video and work it out for
everyone else what does the position
look like well here we go in 3 2 1 okay
white to move once more if you'd like to
go ahead pause the video what is the
best continuation okay and now for the
solution let's see who got it whether
your eyes were opened or not let's see
how you did with this one first move is
rook d3
only move king c8 rook c3 check notice
now that the Rick is on c3 there's no
longer a pin of the Queen now if the
King goes to d8 this is checkmate so the
king has to go on the other on the other
square b8 and the Queen slides over
still to c7 in the final sequence is
really what got me with this puzzle it
is to zigzag with the Queen along the a
and B files and the King has to stay on
the a or b files and in the end the
destination square is B - a little role
reversal initially was the rook playing
to c3 to unpin the Queen well now it is
the Queen posting up on b2 to unpin the
rook which enables
muevate this check million-eight rook a
three-game over what a cool sequence
just wanted to share that one with you
and let me know how you did in the
comment section below
did you solve it blindfolded or not let
me know in the comment section below and
as usual I hope you enjoyed this one
that's all for now take care bye
you